what's up everyone welcome back to the
channel for another interview an
interview that I'm very excited about
because not only do I get to talk about
a really cool new genre film but it's a
feature directorial debut which I think
is one of the most incredible Feats to
achieve in this industry Sung Kang
making his feature directorial debut
with shaky Shivers congratulations man
this film delighted me oh thank you so
much Barry thank you I mean it I mean it
so to go back to the very beginning of
your directing Ambitions to start here
do you remember the day or maybe even
the specific thing that happened that
first made you think to yourself like I
have to direct a feature film well
I think it started you know probably
within the first
five years I started acting you know
professionally
um there was this lack of opportunities
for me as an actor you know and
I
always felt like you know I think
there's more to it than you know playing
fifth to 10th to 15th you know
supporting character that's kind of
one-dimensional or mostly
one-dimensional and I always ask myself
well you know how am I gonna
quench this thirst to do something more
meaningful or have more contribution to
a production
um other than you know playing a small
like co-starring role and uh
yeah I realize you know it's it's it's
that you have to you know create your
own material you have to be behind the
camera you have to create opportunities
for yourself and other people that you
know have the same obstacles so you know
I knew early on if I did not you know
take control of this problem myself then
you know I probably would
you know I use this term that you know
the light behind my artistic light you
know would start dimming you know and um
that would become some jaded actor and
bitter so yeah very early on I knew that
you have to control your own destiny so
writing and directing is the only way
you can do that the light behind your
artistic light I'm not going to forget
that visual that's a it's a really
interesting way to put all of that into
perspective and I can I can understand
and relate to that quite a bit myself
so you decide you want to direct a film
does being very well known for your
acting help when you want to get the
green light on your first feature or is
it the kind of situation where it
requires more convincing where you have
to tell the powers that be like no I am
very capable of doing this as well well
it definitely opens the door you know
definitely people will you know
entertain the idea of sitting down with
you
um and talking with you because you know
if you're known for particular work or
if you've not known it you know being
part of like a big franchise like fast
you know you know people will give you
the benefit of doubt if you will and sit
down with you but still you have to
campaign for yourself just because you
know you've been in a bunch of stuff
doesn't mean that you know you have a
hold of them of The Craft of directing
you know as an actor
which is usually there for a little bit
of pre-production and then you're you
know you're part of production and then
you leave right so you know
post-production was my weak side and and
that was something that you know I had
to learn on my own
um and then I think when you sit down
with somebody especially when it comes
down to you know investing money into
you right it is you know Show Business
there's a business behind this
you know people have to you know feel
um confident that you're going to be
able to execute you're going to be able
to lead this Army
and you know finish the product
um so it's not easy you know if it was
easy everybody would you know be
directing as well you know so
um you know I think you know once you
have the confidence and why you're
directing and you have an understanding
of the overall Journey it takes to make
of fellow message director you know I
think people feel it you know I think
the smart one sit down with you and they
go you know this guy knows or you know
this person knows what they're talking
about so but it took a while you know it
took a while to get the you know the
financing even though our budget is
minimal you know for nothing is free in
life right so for people to Fork over
that kind of money is very challenging I
have a million follow-up questions
before I get too far ahead though I I am
just curious in general are you a big
horror fan
well you know during the during my
childhood I I wouldn't say I was I was
into like the slasher films but I
definitely
you know appreciate it and love films
like you know
um American Werewolf in London you know
Gremlins you know
um you know even Friday you know Freddy
Krueger and you know
um Jason was you know one of the you
know characters that I grew up with and
you know they're they're part of my
video store filmography right so you
know I think as a kid I'm fighting
Saturday nights you get together with
your friends and and you you and you
watch these classic horror films so you
know they were definitely part of my
life and part of why I appreciated my
movies especially the Practical elements
of the you know the the monsters and the
Prosthetics and the artwork that it took
to create a lot of these you know visual
compelling
um you know werewolves and monsters of
that era definitely see a lot of those
influences in your movie right now just
for fun because I love fan casting my
favorite actors in my favorite horror
franchises if you could pick one iconic
horror franchise to join which one would
you pick and why I'd love to play Freddy
Krueger in Nightmare on them streets you
know that that it's the guy that
character was just so fun yeah you know
having experience with prosthetic makeup
and sitting in the chair for four hours
like I did in the Obi when the Obi-Wan
series Star Wars I've had that's the
only part that you know I kind of wonder
if you know I have the stamina to sit in
a makeup chair for months but you know
that character was so fun that sweater
that this stays so iconic and you know
that you know the the knife night knife
finger so I would definitely love that
that'd be on the bucket list for sure
that's lit now on my bucket list I need
you I need to see you play Freddy
Krueger at this point
that's right back back to your film now
so you kind of just touched on this a
little bit in particular with the
post-production but even with all your
experience acting and producing as well
was there any particular thing about
what it takes to direct a feature film
that you didn't even realize was part of
that job where when you had to do it
it's it made you stop and think like wow
I did not realize this was on the list
of duties for a director well you know
the the the concept and the Mastery of
the leadership is something that I think
I just
had a theory of what it took to you know
lead a creative Army to a finish you
know a finished project and it really
was you know also you know I think
channeling and understanding yourself
right like you know
I grew a lot during that process because
you know as an actor usually just
responsible you are responsible for
yourself and your role right but as a
director you are in a way a parent and
you know I lack that experience and I
realized that you know I'm flawed in so
many ways and selfish in so many ways
and stubborn in so many ways and you
know to be able to get the best out of
you know
creative crew and cast you know you have
to you know know yourself and you know
and I think you know find peace in who
you are and you know and accept your
flaws and I think once you do that and
you know people will see that there is
humility in the way you approach
leadership and you know I I do feel like
you know there was a lot of
self-exploration that I didn't know that
I had to go through like every night
you know you're the last one to go to
sleep you know like you can choose to
you know be the person that is gonna
start you know preparing for the next
day's outing you know and you know I
would reflect and go
you know I probably approached that you
know they incorrectly and I could have
been more supportive or could have you
know a bit more engaged and more
empathetic and you know I was like and
so daily you know you're falling on your
face and you have to lift yourself up
right so you know there's a lot of
self-reflection I didn't think I had to
go through so with all of that in mind
is there anything about your experience
directing shaky Shivers that you have
found influencing your own approach to
your work as an actor now where kind of
viewing the craft of acting from a
different vantage point or having a
better understanding of what it takes to
be a director is changing the way you
approach your work in that particular
field okay I
as an actor now you know I know what the
director is going through he has a
million decisions and a more empathetic
you know I try to be
you know that's you know that member of
the family that you know
is thinking ahead for the director you
know like I'm trying to be like three
steps ahead and
um and also you know being empathetic to
what that person is going through
especially if they're having a tough day
you know before it would be about me and
like you know why is that person so
upset or why they behave in that way
you know so it's definitely made me
laugh selfish if you will you know
um
so I mean I think that's a good thing so
you know
um there's a lot of times you know as an
actor you just have to worry about
yourself right and I do
approach my and I use the operative
contribution you know it's like it's not
just about you it's about the whole and
you know the project as a whole and I
think when you have a member
of the team that is you know also
watching out for you you know it's there
um and thinking a few steps ahead for
you
um you know it just it just helps right
so it's it's it's calmed me down a lot
and it's just it I think you know being
a director is just it's just matures you
a lot especially at my age you know so
it's definitely changed my perspective
as an actor I've always been a very big
believer that even if someone just wants
to focus on one particular craft it's
always beneficial to have at least a
little bit of an understanding of what
everyone else on a set has to do and
it'll wind up maybe enhancing your own
work for the better so having those
kinds of experiences I think makes all
the difference
agreed so how about now when directing
your leads here maybe what's what's
something you wish that more directors
had done for you on set in the past that
you strove to do for them to make sure
that they had it on this film I think
because as a direct as actor
I always hoped that I had a director or
you know a leader that was rooting for
you you know
um you know sometimes you know you felt
like you were kind of you know
you know
although and you know and kind of there
to dry you know I had to try if you will
and you know I I wish sometimes the
director would over communicate with me
and just give me validation especially
when I was younger you know like these
days I'm not looking for that or I don't
need it as much but you know when you're
a young person you do need validation
and you know and it could just be in you
know in in a a a physical gesture or
just a look or a wink you know and I'm
extra sensitive to you know the actor's
State of Mind on set and
um and I can see how there's such a thin
line where you know that confidence can
break so you know you have to be you
know the ultimate cheerleader and you
know and and some actors don't need that
but then I think you know actors tend to
be you know insecure you know animals to
begin with so
um I just try to be able to Ultimate
cheerleader for them those vibes and
that support is of the utmost importance
on sets how about uh just in terms of
the techniques you use and the way you
operate is there any particular director
you've worked with the worked with in
the past especially as you were leading
up to directing shaky Shivers that you
found yourself you know observing what
they were doing and maybe applying their
techniques to your own approach to the
work the most
um I had the opportunity to work with
Walter Hill upon a class in his own
right
who did 48 hours and worked at Peck and
PAW and I got to work with them on this
Sylvester Stallone's
um film called Bullet to the Head
um and then I you know years later I got
to work with Robert Rodriguez and the
reason I bring these two directors up is
that
they share everything you know there's
nothing there's no secrets to their to
their craft there's no Voodoo you know
they'll show you all of their notes and
their sketches and you know their
storyboards and their notes and you know
and they get they just have this passion
for filmmaking and also they're not
selfish with their knowledge you know
and you know they ask the the crew in
the cast and know the script and know
what's in their head
um I remember I got to hang out with
Robert Rodriguez
um at his home and you know he invited
uh the cast over and he taught me
something about service is that when the
leader is you know willing to serve you
you know and and
um and he's there to you know to to
stand that creative you know that that
creative those creative juices if you
will
um you know I went over his house and he
made us pizza and he was he didn't just
make us pizza he explained you know why
he uses the certain type of flower and
the type of water and his Clay Oven and
the honey that he uses
for the pizza dessert and the type of
cheese
um and and then he would have us you
know he had he would ask us to go into
his little you know he had a little
drawing room and asked us if we would
gift him with a you know something a
picture or a poem or something and so he
could remember you know our you know
artistic contribution I remember this
evening and I'm like wow this is such a
lovely evening you know and then I would
ask him questions about you know his
previous movies and I go ahead you know
how did you do that and you know what
was that an expensive like shot that was
the budget for that and he would
literally pull out his computer and he
goes let me show you some and he would
break the scenes down and you know and
explain like how you can do something
you know with minimum money and
um and you know explain to me the
importance of an actor that is willing
to you know take risks and try and and
you know
um and just the importance of a cast and
crew that's willing to you know like you
know dance with you right so these
lessons
um and then Walter Hill you know
explaining to me that you know even
though he had
in a prolific career you know as he
started getting older you know it was
interesting where
he said to me you know kid if I when I
was a younger person I wouldn't
understand what you go through as an
actor because you talk about lack of
opportunities as a minority and he goes
I understand that now as an older person
because you know at my age there's this
ageism in Hollywood and you know there's
little opportunities for me and I was
like wow the cruelty of Hollywood you
know like everyone has their time you
know an average director maybe does six
to ten movies in their lifetime right so
you realize that things are finite you
know and enjoying that I think that's
why Walter
you know on set and he was like a kid in
a candy store you know that was his
happy place right so you know I think
all these like you know Wonderful
lessons of you know I think you know
giving me a foundation that
is based in like reality too and also
based in you know like this ethos of
contribution like you know how do I get
back you know and it's like information
you know is free right so you can keep
sharing and keep sharing and that's what
I try to do is that anyone with the
question I go I'll give you all the
answers right and I think you know and
that's how you I think you know make
contribute to better film to the Future
because you have these you know
Wonderful disciples if you will right of
you know this type of ethos and if you
do that because these folks did that to
me you know giving me that you know I
give that back and you know that is
something that you know I I try to
emulate you know as I get older too what
a beautiful answer I mean it's not it's
not quite the same thing but that's why
I love interviewing artists about their
work so much because getting some of
that behind the scenes information out
there you never know who that could
Inspire or how it can enhance someone
else's work and the thought of that
happening even if it's just unlike the
smallest scale just no it Thrills me and
fills my heart thank you so to get into
some specifics here because it is a very
ambitious first feature of all of the
creature design and stunt work required
for the film going into production which
thing did you think was going to be the
most challenging to pull off and then
ultimately was it indeed the most
challenging or did something else Catch
You by surprise well there's a there's a
sequence in the film that's an homage to
the American werewolf and then the
werewolf transformation
um
that the character Karen has or Lucy has
and um
I knew it was going to be challenging
right because you know time is our enemy
money is our enemy but
but because we were blessed with
you know the the gay bartoluses you know
you know his his experience and his
passion for the Practical effects and he
was also Rick Baker disciple you know
that Rick Baker actually
and he you know he worked on American
work from London so he he he knew
exactly what I wanted you know or what I
was going for I was like you know a tip
to the hat too you know that's that
werewolf transformation and American
Wealth and London
um and you know we were fortunate
because we had you know Brooke Markham
who's just the Fantastic actress so if
you know an actress could have you know
pulled that performance off you know it
would it would be borderline really
hokey you know that actually would be
hokey
um and also too you know we just didn't
have time I think that whole sequence I
should have taken a few days minimum
like at least two three days minimum but
we had like two hours right and
um it was
nerve-wracking because I was like this
could be really dumb and not really work
and even when I was shooting I was like
I don't think I have enough coverage and
you know I didn't I I feel like you know
Gabe didn't have enough time to really
you know to to be able to to work on the
Prosthetics on that day because you know
it's like I think he had like a hour and
a half of prep
to put on the to to be because it you
know that that sequence goes in order so
you just you can't just put the
Prosthetics on it like you have to you
know it starts with the hand and you
know you have to put a little bit on the
face and then go you know and then we
focus on the back and there's so many
elements but again without Gabe we
wouldn't have been able to do and then
it's also the magic of editing too and
you know sound design right so it turned
out okay I'm not you know I can't say
that I'm like completely happy with it
but you know that's that's also art and
you know I don't think a director is
ever really satisfied with their work
right so I wish we had more of
everything but I do you know applaud and
I'm so grateful to Brooke and you know
and and gay for you know making that
work out
for what it's worth from my perspective
I think you made the most of the time
and the resources you had and it
perfectly aligns with with the tone of
the film too I've covered so many uh
movies out there that have werewolf
Transformations or or other paranormal
entities for that matter and the movie
essentially hinges on that working and
the entire time it was happening I was
sitting there watching wildly impressed
by what you were all able to pull off so
I I understand that always reaching for
more is a director mentality but you
should be very proud of what you did in
that particular sequence well thank you
so much Perry thank you I mean it I mean
it
um you know I wanted to end with a uh a
question about the ongoing strikes right
now because we are lucky enough to get
to talk to you because we are talking
about your directorial debut right now
but there is a lot happening in this
industry that we like to shine a
spotlight on however we can whenever
possible just to make sure the message
is continuing to get out there as these
situations progress so for you I I know
there's probably many answers to this
particular question but what is
something that maybe you didn't have in
the past as an actor that these
negotiations are pushing for that you
think could make for a better working
experience for you in the future
something that you are eager to have and
progress forward with
um
that's a great question Perry I don't
even know how to answer that I don't I
don't think um
first I mean I don't think um
I don't know I mean that's that's I I I
mean
hmm that's a really good what what
um
well I mean the strike is really
representing
what
the change in what we did have in the
past for instance like residuals right I
mean the our Union has been so good at
you know
protecting our residuals so we could you
know be able to qualify for health
insurance
Etc you know and
um and and you know I know that that's
one of the things that you know our
Union is fighting for because with
streaming you know I checked out you
know yearly would be fourteen hundred
dollars is now around forty dollars
because you know streaming just doesn't
pay residuals
um and you know when
my wife was sick and she had to you know
get medical care
and you you had to meet that you know I
think it's around like thirty thousand
dollars a year to qualify for a sag
Insurance you know the residuals pretty
much were able to cover most of that you
know
um or you know fill in the gaps right so
you know an actor could do a few guest
stars and you know maybe like a small
feature and then you know the residuals
would like to take care of the rest but
today
you know it's it's it's you know it's
almost nothing right so that's something
you know ours Union is fighting to
preserve so you know I
you know I'm not answering a question
but that's something that we die
completely you know agree with because
it's on such a personal level without
residuals I don't think you know I
definitely wouldn't not have been able
to afford you know Health Care you know
and they carry them my wife needed when
she was sick you know and um
and so I I know that's not answering
your question but it's it's you know I
feel like that's something that is very
personal to me you know and this idea of
actors being able to you know subsidize
their you know their income by you know
you know our work from the past and you
know what the residuals allowed us to be
able to you know to to have in terms of
medical care and stuff um you know it's
going away right so it's it's really
it's much much harder like I wonder you
know with you know real estate prices in
LA and New York like how a young actor
you know is able to afford to be able to
go to acting class you know and pay
their rent and have a car and then gas
money and and you know and and have
healthy food you know when I was younger
you know my rent was like five hundred
dollars you know and I could have a
little studio apartment you know and I
could work as a bartender and a delivery
guy and you know have a few part-time
jobs and still make it to auditions but
today you're not able to do that so
residuals are so important you know
um
and so yeah I I mean I know I'm not
answering a question but that's
something that is so important right it
is an answer to that and it's an
important way to answer the question
because it also represents the fact that
unless we see these negotiations through
right now it's going to cause major
problems for actors who want to enter
the industry in the future like at a
point in time actors and writers were
lucky enough to have certain things but
because of the change in the business
model those things are disappearing and
it's going to make it an unsustainable
career path for others in the future and
that just breaks my heart into a million
pieces
yeah so I'm glad we were able to shine a
little bit of a spotlight on that
situation right now because we do not
get an excellent movie like shaky
Shivers without all the wildly talented
artists we have in this industry and
they all deserve to get what they what
they earn for their hard work because
otherwise we do not get great movies and
shows congratulations on shaky Shivers I
I mean what I say it is a delightful
ride and I'll take a moment just to give
give people a sense of of what the vibe
is it made me feel like it made me feel
a little like when I was a kid growing
up becoming a horror lover watching
something like Are You Afraid of the
Dark something that kind of joyfully
explored those kinds of Supernatural
scenarios and simply put it just made me
happy to watch it and I feel like a lot
of genre lovers out there are going to
wind up feeling the same exact way when
they see it in theaters via cineverse
and fathom events they're releasing the
film in theaters for just one night only
on September 21st so do not miss it
because I will also add to that little
description that I gave that it's it is
a great uh it's a great communal watch
like I would love to see it on the big
screen with a bunch of people who are as
passionate about the genre as I am and
who have grown up with an affection for
these types of things so see it in
theaters again congratulations this
movie something else thank you Perry
thank you for your time